upcycling is the process of turning
discarded objects or material into
products of higher quality or value than
the originals and it's become really
popular in Germany and especially in
Berlin
you can even take special tours to visit
shops where upcycling products are made
and sold upcycling is is a design
process and through these design process
you can upgrade the value of materials
that are used our tour guide is Arianna
Nicoletti who owns a shop that sells
upcycle designer clothing she shows us
some examples this shawl was made from a
men's blazer the material for this purse
came from a curtain this cap was made
from old clothing and so was this one
its cuddly these shirts were made from
leftover fabric from the fashion
industry at the end of this season of
the selling season then they have a lot
of leftovers sometimes they have two
meters sometimes they have 5060 meters
every item in the shop is unique like
these armbands made from espresso
capsules fantastic idea it's really
making really unique loads and I think
I'd really think I'd want to spend money
on those well I'm buying something
special and nobody else is like this
wearing it I think it's
next stop ville fleet blitzing us up
cycled fashion store plot singer creates
his designs right in the shop old
clothing becomes new like these slacks
made from pullover sleeves the customers
are impressed with pleasures trendy
designs
looks like new you know like fabric this
was a sleeping bag that may explain why
the jacket sleeves are so warm and comfy
the vest came from a flea market Berlin
has the biggest scene in Europe for
sustainable fashion the people here the
society is already really aware of
sustainability issues we have really
ready public upscaling can also apply to
other products Dietrich Menzel makes
lamps and small furnishings from used
material including musical instruments
this chair was made from an old barrel
old stuff has been given a new lease on
life yes a new life I think that's
really impressive
upcycling is a perfect fit for Berlin
the products are creative distinctive
and environmentally friendly much like
the city itself